Xin chào mừng các bạn đến với khóa học
Ếch Xanh miễn phí từ cơ bản đến nâng cao
dành cho người mới bắt đầu được thực
hiện trên kênh YouTube và Excel bài số
15 các thủ thuật sau hai phần 2/4 trước
khi bắt đầu vào bài học ngày hôm nay
mình sẽ giải đáp với câu hỏi của bài tập
số 14 hôm trước nhé các bạn xem ở cái
câu hỏi của bài số 14 lên ok câu hỏi của
mình là gì ạ Mình sẽ thay cái ô trống
bằng cái đoạn Tech là thiếu dữ liệu và
mình sẽ tô màu vàng cả ô đấy cũng ạ bước
thứ nhất là phải chọn được cái ô trống
đúng không đấy thì đầu tiên mình sẽ Bôi
đen toàn bộ vùng dữ liệu nhé các bạn sẽ
thích bằng ô bất kỳ này các bạn sẽ bấm
cân A đấy hoặc là gì hoặc là các bạn giữ
được trái và các bạn kéo thôi Đấy tức là
mình sẽ lựa chọn toàn bộ cái vùng dữ
liệu này đúng không Bây giờ mình sẽ mở
cái cửa sổ go to xổ lên nhá Thì cái phím
tắt là các bạn sẽ bấm Corolla đấy thì nó
sẽ hiện của cái cửa sổ totu nhá và các
bạn thích chọn cái do tổ đây Thì như vậy
cái cửa sổ dos cao thủ đã hiện ra đúng
không Bây giờ con sẽ thích chọn
Ừ rồi con sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy là dị
toàn bộ cái ô trống đây này Nó đã được
lựa chọn rồi Các bạn thấy em nó sẽ có
cái màu đen ở đây này Bây giờ mình sẽ
viết cái chữ thiếu dữ liệu và mình tô
màu vàng nhé đấy thì đầu tiên mình có
thể tô với màu vàng trước đây các bạn sẽ
vào với cả hôm này các bạn sẽ thích cái
màu ở đây lại ví dụ Các bạn chọn là cái
màu vàng nhá hoặc là màu là thì tùy các
bạn thì ở đây lỡ yêu cầu lòng màu vàng
đúng không phải gọi sẽ tích vào đây là
màu vàng tiếp theo mình sẽ ghi là thiếu
dữ liệu nhá thì bạn gọi luôn là diện
thiếu dữ liệu nhá Đấy sau khi còn gõ
xong thì con phải giữ phím cần chôn rồi
Các bạn ơi bấm enter nhá các bạn Nhớ nha
các bạn giữ phím quyền chung và các bạn
muốn enter đấy thì như vậy là diệt toàn
bộ cái ô mà rẽ ô trống đây nó đã được
chị ạ Nó đã đường võ cái chữ người thiếu
dữ liệu rồi đấy cá có thể tô đậm lên
cũng được để mình có thể cho màu đậm lên
đấy thì tùy các bạn nhé Bây giờ chọn sẽ
thích bằng ô bất kỳ để mình thoát trong
việc lựa chọn các kiểu này để bạn sẽ rất
là hai ạ
Ừ như vậy là mình đã xong cái câu hỏi
cho cái bài tập về nhà nhá các bạn đóng
lại mình sẽ đi vào cái bài số 15 hôm nay
các bạn thấy nhé mình sẽ để cái link tải
file thực hành trong phần mô tả thế giới
video thì tốt nhất là các bạn tải về các
bạn buổi theo dõi và thực hành cùng mình
nhá Nếu như bạn nào cũng biết cách tải
về thì các bạn có thể theo dõi Cái bài
đầu tiên trong bài đấy mình đã hướng dẫn
các bạn Chi tiết cái cách để các bạn tải
về thì cái file mà tải về thì nó sẽ làm
một cái quay lén các bạn sẽ giải nén ra
nhé và các bạn sẽ thấy nó sẽ có 2 file
một một cái là file thực hành này và một
cái file là câu hỏi cho cái bài tập về
nhà trong Bài học này Hôm nay mình sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn ba cái thủ thuật thứ
nhất là tạm cái danh sách xổ xuống hay
còn gọi là nước Dallas Thứ hai là mình
sẽ chọn cái xe nâng cam và thứ ba là
mình sẽ giới thiệu qua với các bạn về
cái thanh trạng thái say goodbye ấy thì
cái thủ thuật thứ nhất là tạo với danh
sách xổ xuống dropdownlist nhé Đây mình
sẽ vào với
ý là cái thủ thuật đầu tiên là tạo danh
sách xổ xuống đúng không ạ Đấy thì bạn
Thúy Nga ở bên phải là mình đã hướng dẫn
các bạn là các bước để tạo danh sách xổ
xuống rồi bạn chỉ cần làm theo thế này
thôi nhé bây giờ giả sử cái giới tính
mình muốn nhập cái danh sách xổ xuống
nhá mình sẽ xóa cái này nên để bạn chọn
mới lại thì cái danh sách xổ xuống là gì
Chắc là khi bạn tích vào một cái ông này
thì nó sẽ có các tùy chọn để các bạn
thích và thôi các bạn không phải gõ tay
nữa để anh thì bây giờ giả sử mình có ba
cái kiểu giới tính là nam nữ và khác
đúng ạ Đấy thì mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
một số cách cách để các bạn dễ các bạn
tạm với danh sách xổ xuống ở đây lại thì
đầu tiên các bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ
liệu mà các bạn muốn tạo danh sách xổ
xuống nhé sau đó thì các bạn xem vào cái
thẻ ra ta Các bạn chọn data validation ở
đây đấy thì một cái cửa sổ
data-validation ở hiện ra nhá các bạn sẽ
thích vào cái thẻ setting thế này một Ô
lâu các bạn sẽ chọn cho mình là dễ là
Lead cái phần short nhắc họ sẽ gõ cho
mình các cái kiểu giới tính ví
ở huyện Nam này Phải nữ phải khác Đấy
tức là mình có ba cái kiểu giới tính này
các bạn sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy toàn thấy
chưa khi các bạn tạo xong thì nó sẽ có
một cái ô nhỏ này lại để con chọn giới
tính Ví dụ mình chọn hàng nhanh lại cái
ôm thứ hai cũng vậy nhé ví dụ bạn Bùi
Viện Bùi Thị béo này có thích bài này
các bạn sẽ chọn cái tính là nữ đấy các
bạn Bún Đậu đây ví dụ mình cho giới tính
Nhật khác đây thì lúc này các bạn chỉ
cần kích chọn thôi các bạn không phải gõ
nữa Cái này cũng rất là ngay nó sẽ đảm
bảo cho các bạn là không bị nhầm nhá Đấy
để xóa cái danh sách xổ xuống này thì
các bạn làm như thế nào thì gọi sẽ Bôi
đen trong vùng danh sách mà lúc nãy Các
Bạn tạo cái thiện cái tạo danh sách chọn
xuống nhá hay còn gọi là nửa lít thì có
những bạn gọi là danh sách xổ xuống thì
tùy các bạn nhé thì đầu tiên mình sẽ Bôi
đen các cái ô mà mình tạo cái danh sách
chọn xuống rồi bây giờ các bạn lại vào
thẻ data Các bạn chọn điện
data-validation đấy Sau đó các bạn tích
cái cleoli để tạo sẽ bấm ok thì như vậy
Ở đây đánh mất cái danh sách xổ xuống ạ
đấy là cái cách mà
Nghe danh sách xổ xuống nhá Bây giờ mình
xóa đi cái Cách thứ 2 để miêu tả cái
danh sách xổ số là gì ạ Mình sẽ Liệt kê
các cái giới tính ở đây thì đầu tiên các
bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu mà các
bạn muốn tạo cái danh sách xổ xuống nhá
đấy các bạn vào thẻ đa tăng Các bạn chọn
data validation thì vẫn là trong cái thẻ
setting này cái nhục câu lâu các bạn sẽ
chọn cho mình là gì là Lead đấy ở cái
phần short nhá các bạn sẽ tích vào ô trò
này sau đó bạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái ô mà mình
muốn tạo danh sách xổ xuống đây ví dụ ba
cái ô này đây thì lúc này các bạn không
phải gõ nữa mà cái phần sọt này nó sẽ
thay bằng một cái ô tham chiếu ở đây là
từ viện từ g14 đến giờ 16 để bạn sẽ bấm
ok thì như vậy Ở đây nó cũng có cái danh
sách xổ xuống rồi để con chọn lấy cảm
thấy rất là hai ạ Nếu như các bạn gõ vào
đây nhá các bạn gõ một cái giới tính ví
dụ giới tính là gì là gà thì hạn thì Nhé
thì nó sẽ báo lỗi này nó sẽ không cho
bạn gõ đấy cái cách này rất là ngay nó
chỉ cho các bạn Nhập thôi
A gọi là nữ chẳng hạn thì lại Ok nếu như
cái phần mà các bạn gọi nó lằng một
trong các phần ở danh sách xổ xuống đây
thì ok Còn nếu như các bạn có một cái
giới tính khác ví dụ như là gì ạ Ví dụ
nhà trai ở lại nhé thì nó sẽ không cho
bạn gõ đâu đấy ok xanh thủ thuật thứ hai
là thì mình sẽ chọn xe nâng cao thì đầu
tiên được gì Các bạn sẽ vào cái thẻ hôm
này để họ sẽ vào điện firestick đợi cách
chọn cái file ở đây lấy hoặc phím tắt là
điện internet nhé họ sẽ bấm tăng cho
phép thì nó sẽ hiện một cái cửa sổ là
file list nhá thì còn chú nhá ở đây nó
sẽ có hai cái thẻ là thẻ file vào thẻ
rơi Tuyết thì trong Bài học này mình sẽ
giới thiệu các bạn Thể file Thôi nhá thì
bạn sẽ nhập cái ô mà các bạn cần tìm
kiếm Ví dụ mình muốn tìm cái sản phẩm 01
đi nhé tại thì họ sẽ ghi là sp ạ Còn
cách ra là không một đấy Nãy sao nó có
diện tích bằng
Anh ở các bạn sử nhất ở đây mình hướng
dẫn là chưa đầy đủ Cái này là nhập vào
từ cần tìm kiếm và các bạn giải thích
vào cái chữ file trước đã nhá Đấy thì nó
sẽ hiện ra gì nó sẽ hiện ra một cái danh
sách toàn bộ cái kết quả ở dưới này các
bạn thấy rằng rất là hay đây là bộ Kết
quả đây thì các bạn sẽ bấm tăng trên a
lại cảm thấy chưa thì sau khi các bạn
Bun cao cho ai thì toàn bộ các sản phẩm
01 ở đây đã được Bôi đen này lại sẵn có
01 này sạc vào 01 này vào lúc này các
bạn có thể tùy chọn nhá Ví dụ như bấm
lâu đi còn thấy toàn bộ các sản phẩm 01
đã được lựa chọn ở đây các bạn có thể
hiện các bạn có thể tô màu đỏ hay các
bạn có thể tố đậu lại thì tùy các bạn
nhá như vậy là diện Đây là cái cách để
mình chọn cái sản phẩm nâng cao này Ví
dụ mình chọn là khu vực miền Bắc thời
hạn này nhá thì bạn cũng làm tương tự
thôi các bạn sẽ bấm cho phép này đấy các
bạn sài gòn cái chữ bắt vào đây lấy gạo
sẽ chọn cái file này và bạn sẽ bấm càng
chỗ Na thì như vậy là dễ toàn bộ cái khu
vực phía Bắc đã được lựa chọn ở đây cảm
thấy rất là hay Sẽ Lau đi vào lúc này
các bạn có thể tùy chỉnh nhá ví dụ miền
Bắc
ô tô màu đẹp mình sẽ tô màu xanh ngày đi
chẳng hạn thế đấy còn miền Nam nhé Bây
giờ mình sẽ thích cả các bạn ạ Bây giờ
các bạn lại bấm cho phép Giả sử miền Nam
để bạn sẽ chọn điểm các bạn phải ôn và
các bạn bấm càng nhớ ta để miền Nam mình
sẽ tô màu gì Các bạn cần lâu đi mình sẽ
chọn các màu mà bạn mong muốn nhá đại ví
dụ Việt Nam mình trong vào ngày lại
tương tự miền Trung các bạn thích tô màu
nào thì các bạn là như vậy nhá Đấy là
cái cách lựa chọn nâng cao đấy khá là
hay đúng không ạ Mình sẽ vào cái thủ tục
không ba cái thanh trạng thái đấy mình
sẽ thu nhỏ cái cửa sổ này lại người sẽ
kéo cái này lên để cho con thấy là cái
thanh trạng thái nó nằm ở dưới này bạn
chú ý nhé các thanh trạng thái nằm ở
dưới này Đấy bây giờ cạn sẽ Bôi đen Cái
vùng dữ liệu này đấy còn thấy chưa thì
khi mà các bạn Bôi đen Cái vùng dữ liệu
thì bạn sẽ thấy chứ ở dưới thanh trạng
thái này nó sẽ hiện rất là nhiều thông
tin đầu tiên là gì Cái trung bình đây
thì nó sẽ lấy biển
khi chọn chủ nhà những cái phần mà liên
quan đến phần tính số liệu ví dụ như là
tính trung bình tĩnh mắc tính tập thì nó
sẽ chỉ cậu cái giá trị là số đấy thôi
còn những cái ô mà rách thì nó sẽ không
tính á thì bạn thấy điểm trung bình là
94 này mắc là 18 và dị ạ xong ở đây là
119 đấy Còn cái cao ba ngày đây nghĩa là
gì nó sẽ đến toàn bộ các cái ô mà mình
Bôi đen rồi đây để nó sẽ ra ba ha bây
giờ để thêm các thành phần thì còn nháy
chuột phải vào cái vị trí của status 3
nhá và các bạn sẽ chọn các cái gì cái
chức năng mà các bạn mong muốn Ví dụ như
chậm với chức năng này minimart thế nào
Cái giá trị nhỏ nhất là lấy ví dụ mình
chọn thêm là cái diện Mình sẽ chọn thêm
cái 5m Cao đây chắc rằng nó sẽ đến số
đúng không đấy các bạn sẽ bấm ra ngoài
Để con thoát còn thấy nhớ như vậy là gì
ạ Kể như mâm chỗ là giá trị nhỏ nhất
trong cái vùng dữ liệu mà mình Bôi đen
lúc đấy nó sẽ là bốn này lại còn cái 50
khô khao chắc là nó sẽ đến cái ô mà chứa
giá trị số thôi
ở những cái điểm ở đây này và tổng điểm
là giá trị số đó sẽ là 21 còn cao đây 32
chỗ nào nó là nó sẽ đến cả cái chuỗi ký
tự Ở đây bây giờ để bỏ các thành phần mà
các bạn không muốn hiển thị ở cái tên
thứ ba này nhá thì đôi khi nó hiển thị
nhiều quá mình không muốn đúng không Các
bạn có thể nhớ được phải vào đây các bạn
bỏ chọn các thành phần mà mình không
muốn đi Ví dụ nằm chờ tức là đến những
cái số này Vinamilk cũng không cần mắc
sinh năm thì cũng không cần nhận đấy nhá
các bạn thích ra ngoài bạn đấy chứ lúc
này nó chỉ còn các thành phần ở đây thôi
rất là hai ạ Như vậy là mình đã xong cái
bài giảng của ngày hôm nay bây giờ mình
sẽ đi vào cái câu hỏi của bài số 15 Ok
câu hỏi của số 15 là gì ạ Ở đây mình sẽ
là diện mình sẽ yêu cầu các bạn tạo cái
danh sách xổ xuống ở đây là gì Cách thứ
nhất là mình gọi trực tiếp này Cách thứ
hai mình sẽ chọn vùng danh sách và cái
cách để tạo của danh sách xổ xuống thông
minh đấy tức là diện nếu như mà các bạn
điền thêm các
Ừ đấy thì cái phần danh sách xổ số máy
sẽ tự động cập nhật lại thì sẽ có ba cái
cách để làm cái phần danh sách xổ xuống
thông minh nhà thì bạn sẽ tìm hiểu rõ
nghiên cứu và các bạn làm nhé thì yêu
cầu tối thiểu là các bạn phải làm được
cái phần này lại còn cái phần nâng cao
này chỉ cần có thể nghiên cứu hoặc các
bạn có thể tìm trên kênh của mình thì
mình cũng đã có một cái bài về cái phần
này rồi Nếu còn thích thì con thì nên
kênh và bạn sẽ xem trước nhé Ok như vậy
là mình đã kết thúc bài học ngày hôm nay
ở đây cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi các bạn
nhớ đăng ký Kênh để cập nhật video mới
nhất của gà cũng như chia sẻ để giúp mọi
người cùng học xem nhé Xin chào và hẹn
gặp lại ở